NYPD orders full mobilization plan all
uniformed officers are on standby as
extra man power is deployed to Ring to
Ring Of Steel around Manhattan's DA's
office amid fears of violence after
Trump's indictment I really don't think
there's that that New York City is Maga
country enough to the point that they
have to worry about a bunch of trump
supporters showing up the Manhattan DA's
office
I'm sorry they're going to March them
all down into the tunnels for drills
next and then we know what happens we've
seen The Dark Knight Rises oh that's
right
and then they're going to release all
the inmates from their jails oh man I've
seen the Warriors yeah jeez well I
wonder I wonder what New York would be
like if I don't know 8 000 people
convicted to villains were just released
all those coveted patients are crawling
out of the old person's homes those
Power electric chairs they live
underground yeah so anyway I find this
funny because um let me see if I have
this uh this tweet somehow somewhere
where is this I think people are just
like so paranoid they just don't want to
risk it right like January 6 was such a
disaster and and it was a disaster at
like multiple levels of failing to be
ready for what was going to happen I
think for New York they're publishing
like better safe than sorry because oh
my God if something got repeated where
they weren't ready it's just gonna look
so bad on everybody involved sure we
have this uh we have this video coming
out of Tennessee where a bunch of
leftists
stormed the capital and fought with
police
they actually made their way into the
chamber
in what conservatives are calling an
Insurrection so I mean that's basically
it look they're kind of playing with
cops and people are getting arrested
and it happened in Kentucky too they uh
but like this happens all the time I
mean it's funny there were there were
numerous protests by the left where they
actually were banging on the doors of
the Supreme Court who actually went
inside to uh uh the the the
Congressional buildings and shut down
legislative sessions and they were never
considered that big of a deal and even
right now it's like the media is not
covering this like I said big of a deal
to shut down your capital state capitals
I guess don't matter I don't know what
well it matters but just how much does
it matter there is covering it right
that was a video by the media right yeah
someone posted it was Kelsey Gibbs yeah
Kelsey Gibbs posted and then deleted it
Greg price got a copy of it and reposted
it and then maybe she reposted it again
uh it looked like it really wasn't
I don't think anyone got hurt typically
what we mean when we say like the news
doesn't cover it is that like sure local
Atlas may run the story but is it
getting headline attention is it getting
Prime Time attention is it it didn't
shut down the the authorization of the
new president of the United States which
is what January 6 was they were trying
to like slow or stop the counting of the
votes to get Biden elected or something
like that so it was like a federal
election that was what made that one
such a big deal plus it was high profile
and it was kind of voted on by our
president I think it was a big deal too
he did say Donald Trump was involved in
setting it up directly you know not not
a lot not the Bible said but peacefully
marched to listen apologize just getting
the people in the vicinity he was
probably I think it was something he
said for months that they were going to
steal our election from us and we need
to fight like held the keeper I think it
was more of that than the March
peacefully thing but but he said much
peacefully and there was a there was a
there was a permitted rally at the
Capitol okay how can you go okay we're
backing up a little bit yeah how can you
take the one thing that Biden said on
stage one time as definitive proof that
he was TR that he was actually trying to
withhold aid but the news they said he
did and Trump literally said that we
didn't fight like hell he didn't say
storm the capital in those exact words
what does fight
means the capital you're you're yeah
it's not an argument if Joe Biden said
on stage could you imagine if I told
this guy I did this and everyone went oh
no he literally said he did a thing and
we're like hey if he said he did that we
should investigate Trump said fight and
then later now go March peacefully it's
like well those are metaphors the left
says fight all the time we don't mean
physically we mean spiritually we mean
sure politically it's followed or that
was followed up by months of saying that
like they're going to steal the election
from you you have to fight to save your
country like you don't think that that
type of rhetoric can directly lead to
people saying like so our election is
being stolen like Trump said is being
stolen and we need to fight like go to
the Capitol and fight to save our
country in that line do you blame trans
activists for calling for fighting when
this person went and shot up a church or
a great school for the trans shooter
yeah I mean they've been saying it's
genocide non-stop over and over again
and they've been saying get up weapons
and you have to fight yeah but I don't
know why I don't know why that shooter
did the shooting do you so so the police
said there's a Manifesto and that they
did say that the working theories that's
related to the identity of the shooter
okay wait wait wait you said two totally
are the police saying that it was okay
so so I want to be very specific yeah
wait yeah let's I'd be curious because I
read four different articles I was
trying to find out was anything from
this Manifesto release I know the media
is saying they should release it they
will understand as the police has not
commented on the material and the
manifestia what do they say about it
specifically the it was uh uh the police
chief I guess he was asked specifically
did the gender identity of the shooter
Playa role he says the theory is that is
the case
we're investigating et cetera et cetera
I heard that that's actually what he
said okay I don't know what that means
like because it could mean what you're
saying so let's say that in the
manifesto they're right they're um
they're saying things like I've been
watching a whole bunch of YouTube
commentators like watch saying that
there is a trans genocide and I need to
go and take action to prevent that then
I would say that's horrible and people
that aren't saying actually even if
they didn't say that the people that are
saying there's a transgenocide we need
to fight should be held accountable I
think that's a bad thing if you believe
in stochastic terrorism I think that
that's definitely that but if it's
something like where the person is like
oh like I'm trans to people in my life
don't accept me I'm gonna go shoot up a
school I think that's meaningfully
different than inspired by rhetoric from
people calling for violence right
so when we see these protests from far
left it's like at the Capitol like in
Kentucky and Tennessee do you think the
storming of those capitals is the fault
of people like vosh saying you've got to
take I don't know well those my
understanding is the storming of those
capitals was for gun reform Kentucky was
trans rights they were they were holding
up trans right signs was it trans right
I thought that was in response to the
shooting sure sure but no no Kentucky
was that they're banning uh I think it
was Kentucky right they're banning it
might have been in Kentucky for
Tennessee I think it was for firearms
right Tennessee was Firearms but it
overlapped with that that issue it was
primarily a Firearms protest can so
let's just say Kentucky the starting of
the capital there where they're in the
gallery and they're being arrested and
they're holding up trans signs do you
think this the the suspense of that the
the the the the the inhibition of that
legislative session and the storming of
that capital is the result is the full
somebody is if somebody's activist
saying take up arms and go fight sure if
somebody is storming buildings I think
they should be held legally accountable
they're trying fasting they absolutely
should be and I think that people that
are using alarmistrator to get people to
go and fight whether that's Donald Trump
or whether that's farther people on
YouTube
um
you got to be careful Hassan does it but
he says only in video games well you
unless it's an imminent call like vague
calls like hey go do this thing that's
not illegal that's protective First
Amendment but if you say on this day at
this time do this thing then that's an
imminent threat I understand that's
illegal under the first time the issue
there's a lot of people saying that
there's a trans genocide incoming so buy
firearms that feels a little bit like
great replacement rhetoric except on the
left instead of the right to me were
people on the right sometimes will say
things like immigrants are invading
they're taking everything you need to
buy fires to protect yourself from
spooky immigrants that are replacing
white people that feel similar to people
saying there's a transgenocide by
firearms because Republicans are going
to take your rights away that that type
of like any type of rhetoric that is
basically stating that like your life is
on the line by a gun in my opinion is
like very very unhealthy for the state
of the country I agree I don't like the
metaphor fight for your rights it's been
around my entire life you gotta fight
for your rights in the United States
they literally did 250 years ago sure
um and throughout the ages they have had
to do that they have done it literally
with weapons and so the idea that we
need to we're we got into a fight
yesterday oh we mean we are arguing
that's not a real like what does fight
even mean yeah Elizabeth come on come on
well I mean that's what we're talking
about the word fighting like if you say
go fight for your right are you really
encouraging violence okay fine but like
typically every political organization
says fight for your rights and they are
not implying physical violence I am
relying a struggle against a political
machine to encourage people to vote and
to to get in politicians and get policy
in place so if someone's on a heavy dose
of psychoactives and they hear that and
they go fight physically you've got to
put it on the person you got to blame
the person the thought not the person
that said I think we have to have like a
more holistic intelligent view of this
what I would say is you have to look at
the totality of rhetoric and you've got
to ask where does it lead if somebody is
saying like listen um lawmakers are
coming for your rights you guys need to
fight for your rights okay like we got
to do that that's fine whatever but if
somebody's saying like you are being
eliminated from this country people are
trying to genocide you they're going to
use whatever means possible to take you
out you need to get armed you need to
train you need to be ready for when
these people come to town like that's
like okay what the right exactly
yes right you have to look at the
totality of the rhetoric it's not just
like a one statement it's like how is it
being presented at all what we are
seeing with these posters like trans day
of Vengeance it was like they had
pictures of guns on it they're it's
being accompanied by posters that say
take up your arms no one is coming to
save you and videos of these activists
saying quite literally to beat people
did you see that one they got like a
club made of a curtain rod and they're
like beat them beat them hurt them
although I'd say we have to be really
careful about because on how big some
things like for some of these trans
organizations that people are obsessing
over the the trans day of Vengeance and
then there was another one like the
trans
um resistance something Network or
whatever trans radical activist Network
yeah like I don't even know if these
things exist
um like I see a lot of like I know Fox
News I think I had a few thousand
followers yeah like well on Twitter like
that they're the ones organizing the the
event in DC tomorrow yeah but I'm
curious how many people are going to
even show up to that because I looked at
that page and it's like a WordPress page
with like two links but that's what it
always is and the Twitter page has like
300 followers and no names attached
you'll get a few hundred people to show
up I bet it's a Russian up oh yeah
Russia I mean honestly uh I would not be
surprised if it was Russia or China or
both oh wait did they cancel it oh
apparently they canceled the April first
thing
April breaking news brought to you on
the Tim
cast podcast what was the April first
thing the trans day adventure oh they
canceled it what a horrible name I know
where did you get that from where was
that news
oh that's good they did the right thing
I think that was definitely it was a
violent call so they I think that was
the right move
the organization says this action is not
happening due to Credible threat to life
and safety oh wow I think fight I think
fight for your rights okay Vengeance
starts to get a little bit weird though
Revenge also the word Revenge I don't
like the word Revenge because uh can you
have peaceful Revenge I guess you can
watching someone fail is like a form of
Revenge if you're like me not doing it I
would say that's an unconventional use
of the word though
yeah
Vengeance that implies past wrongdoing I
do think it's absolutely insane that
after what happened on Monday the
media's response to this was was very
very much like oh the poor trans
Community whereas they typically don't
do that for any other mass shooting they
don't know
there's like white dudes like yeah but
when you they're really poor white
people but you know I mean like even the
other trans Shooters right with like
Aberdeen Colorado Springs Denver they
didn't come out and say the same thing
it's like this one they did yeah but I
think for the I think for this one
there's a pretty big deal about it being
a trans person which I don't think it
was necessarily made as big a deal for
the for the past one so and then I think
that the temperature is up really high
right now
because apparently Republicans have
nothing else to talk about but trans
people so we're like all focused and
fixated on trans people right now so
when a shooting happens with it I don't
think it's Republicans I think it's both
Republicans and Democrats Republicans
are obsessed with transcript right now
but Democrats are you know putting books
like genderqueer in schools or I should
say schools are putting those in place
Loudoun County we saw we saw a
republican get elected in Virginia
primarily because of what happened in
London County which is literally two
seconds you get in the car you have 20
seconds you're in Loudon and it's
because these schools they had sexual
assaults they had these books depicting
graphic things for kids and then when
parents wanted something done about it
Democrats called them bigots and ignored
the problem so they turned to
Republicans Republicans embraced it yeah
but isn't this like what our school
boards are for like don't you go to your
school meetings you say we don't want
this here and then you talk to the super
Princess have you watched those meetings
uh some of them but when the parents go
and present the books they get kicked
out or silenced and told they can't
speak about it
for really for all of them all I didn't
say all of them well because I was
because I I can imagine it happening at
like 100 minutes but here's my issues I
wanted to speak in Loudoun County they
changed the rules so that he wasn't
allowed to so he had to rent a basement
apartment to be able to speak was Matt
Walsh a resident of that County no and
you didn't need to be anyone was allowed
to speak at these meetings about issues
so when they found out a prominent
conservative was coming they changed the
rule to Bar him from coming so he had to
become a resident that was not a rule
normally thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time